Now, having introduced distributed shared memory, I want to give sort of a
birds eye view of the history of shared memory systems over
the last oh, 20 plus years. My intent is not
to go into the details of everyone of
these different systems, because that can take forever, but
it is just to give you sort of the space occupied by all the efforts that have
gone on in building shared memory systems, both
in hardware and in software. I encourage you
to surf the web to identify papers and
literature on these different systems that have been built
over time, just to get a perspective on how far we have come in the space of
building shared memory systems. A few thoughts, on
the software side, software DSM was very first thought
of in the mid 80s. The Ivy system that was built at Yale University by Kai
Li and the Clouds Operating System that was
built at Georgia Tech and there were similar systems
built at UPenn. This, I would say, is
the beginning of Software Distributed Shared Memory. Later
on, in the early' 90s, systems like Munin
and TreadMarks were built. I would call them perhaps
a second generation of Distributed Shared Memory
systems. And in the later half of the
90s, there were systems like Blizzard, Shasta,
Cashmere and Beehive. That took some of the
ideas from the early 90s even further. And in parallel with the software DSM, I
would say there was also a completely different
track that was being pursued. And that is,
providing structured objects in a cluster for
programming. And systems such as Linda and Orca,
were done in the early 90s. Stampede at
Georgia Tech was done in concert with the
Digital Equipment Corporation in the mid 90s
and continued on, later on, into Stampede Rt
and PTS, and in fact, in a later
lesson, we'll talk about Persistent Temporal Streams. And
this particular axis of development of structured
distributed shared memory is attractive because it
gives a higher level abstraction than just
memory to computations that needs to be
built on a cluster. Early hardware shared
memory systems such as BBN Butterfly and
Sequent Symmetry appeared in the market in
the mid 80s and, the synchronization paper
that we saw earlier by Mellor-Crummey and
Scott used BBN Butterfly and Sequent Symmetry as
the experimental platform for the evaluation of
the different synchronization algorithms. KSR-1 was another shared
memory machine that was built in the
early 90s. Alewife was a research prototype that
was built at MIT, DASH was a research prototype that was built at Stanford and
both of them looked at how to scale up beyond an SMP, and
build a truly distributed shared memory machine.
And commercial versions of that started appearing.
SGI silicon graphics built SGI origin 2000
as a scalable version of a distributed
shared memory machine. SGI Altix later on
took it even further, thousands of processors
exist in SGI Altix as a large-scale shared
memory machine. IBM Bluegene is another example. And today,
if you look at what is going on
in the space of high performance computing. It is
clusters of SMPs which have become the work
horses in data centers. I very much want you
to reflect on the progress that has been
made in shared memory systems. And, invite you to,
look at, some of the details of machines
that have been built in the past, either
in the hardware or in software, so that
you can learn the progress that has been made.